these comfort shoes come with two
interchangeable insoles one is an
anatomically shaped footbed with good
arch support the other is a reflexology
footbed that massages your feet while
you walk the top of the shoe is made of
leather
an operator spreads the cowhide on a
cutting table and positions of part
shaped steel die over it with a press he
forces the die through the leather the
die has blades on both sides so after
cutting apart for the right shoe he
flips it over and cuts the same part for
the left shoe
they stencil on guide marks for
stitching and stamp on a production
number they place the part under a
template and run it through a lateral
knife this thins the leather where will
overlap adjoining parts so the thickness
of the upper shoe is uniform throughout
now sewers begin assembling the upper
they glue the parts for the lining
together because stitches that are on
the inside of the shoe can sometimes
irritate the foot the lining is made of
soft calf leather except for a small
piece of rougher goat leather at the
back to grip the heel
they sew in the lining one section at a
time
this machine punches holes and embeds
eyelets into the upper then a sower
attaches two more parts of the upper the
tongue and the vamp another sower
finishes the upper by stitching on the
vamp ring they put the upper into a mold
on a forming machine the machine works
like an iron applying both heat and
pressure to form the heel cap into the
perfect shape the next forming machine
uses the same process to round the toe
cap then they steam the upper and insert
a last alas tis a foot shaped plastic
form that matches the specific shape and
size of the shoe they place the upper
into a heat setter the heat forms the
upper to the shape of the last
they place the upper in a template of
the shoes outer sole and trace the top
they grind the leather below that line
this Ruffins the surface to help with
asian the apply heat activated glue to
the roughened area and the sole which is
made of molded polyurethane they let the
glue dry then they activate the glue
with the heater and join the upper and
sole they place the shoe in a vacuum
press the press sucks out the air while
drawing the upper insole tightly
together next they add an anatomically
shaped footbed insole the second set of
insoles goes in the shoe box these shoes
are designed with enough room to insert
a custom orthotic device if needed